alors on va revenir sur angela llorente
alors qu'ils ont déjà leur ntc l'app
apple a fait le casting d'une émission
qui avait très bien marché les marges
rire d'animateur c'était le loft de loft
sur m6 une grande houle à l époque monte
monte monte personne qui continue de
monter malgré mon départ ce qui n'a rien
à voir bien évidemment angela lorente a
un peu balancé sur les castings
d'aujourd'hui ça fait un petit peu alors
c'était un peu aigri c'était mieux avant
et maintenant c'est de la merde voilà
regard des produits l'île de la
tentation en tournée trois jours pour un
épisode c'est aller qu'on les sait qu'il
se passe des choses ont envoyé ce qui se
passe et puis on m'aide en fait mais on
monte ce qu'il y avait de mieux dans
cette histoire aujourd'hui par exemple
sur les marseillais se déplacent à alain
demi-journée fondé à l'épisode et demi
et c'est normal qu'à ce moment là l'un
des bijoux l'espace pas grand-chose
abonnés dans une demi journée et se
passe pas grand chose donc du coup on
dit voilà bah embrasser suit la fh tout
avec celle là fait une séquence de dix
minutes voilà c'était vingt ans on
parlait quinquennat est la raison moi je
suis désolé peut-être j'aurais pas
balancer sur le casting
mais en fait le cheminement en fait
trois jours pour faire l'émission
effectivement on devait tourner
plusieurs jours pour avoir une belle
émission maintenant c ra quo si vous
n'aviez pas avoir ces bâtiments
répondent vous n'aviez pas mêmes
conditions aussi de tournage parce que
avant vous n'aviez pas les mêmes règles
au niveau du csa donc c'était beaucoup
plus souple avait c'était beaucoup plus
trash nous aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a fait sur des
téléréalités j'ai participé oui dans les
pratiques du souper l'émission c à
présenter alors je vous explique tout
sur ce cette légende autour de la
piscine
à l'époque il y avait sur tps schengen
est plus un canal 24 24 ou les gens pays
il y en a plus m alors ça c'est joué
comme pour star ac' pays à l'époque
d'euros je crois par mois pour avoir le
flux 24 24 et effectivement on pouvait
se choisir vous pouvez voir tout ce
qu'il reste dans la maison pendant 24
heures ils sauf que le conditions et
lancé un je dis on découvre le casting à
l'époque lohan a été l'émission démarre
ça marche ça marche bien mais c'est pas
non plus tout de suite à un raz-de-marée
il faut que ils vont faire dans la
piscine des galipettes avec jean-edouard
pour que les bornes où on a un flux 24
24 il n'y a pas de time 17 à l'époque
dame à la maintenance des missions vous
appuyez sur un bouton
en fait on peut décaler la caméra on
voit pas les choses qu'on doit pas boire
à les bâillonner passa donc qu'est-ce
qui se passe eux ils sont dans la
piscine avec jean-edouard ils font ce
qu'ils ont à faire est effectivement
l'image passe tel quel à la télévision
et ça fait un buzz énorme mais c'est la
seule c'est là c'est la seule scène un
peu un peu entre guillemets trash qui
était diffusée dans les dernièrs que
franchement entre le losc et maintenant
excusez moi je préfère ce sont entre
autres un bon candidat et et les miens
franchement c'est en fait la différence
et centre voltaire et
on négocie et gris que janvier la
lorraine ils sont pas contents parce
qu'en fait il c'est normal c'est humain
on n'aime pas ce qu'on voit de nouveau
qui nous a un peu dépassé aujourd'hui
samedi
excusez moi mais par des marseillais
d'accord elle n'a jamais produit les
marseillais elle ne sait pas que c'est
et comment ça fonctionne
la production des marseillais donc quand
on le prend en exemple une émission
qu'elle ne connaît pas qu'elle n'a pas
produit et dans laquelle elle n'a pas
participé je trouve ça injuste et c'est
juste et gris je suis désolé bagages
vous répondre franchement moi ils sont
grâce à vous je rencontre ces fameux
candidat quand vous les voyez à table on
a déjeuné ensemble médicaux des as qui
sont superbes
ils sont adorables y parle bien français
ils sont intelligents ils extraient bien
qu ils soient des visions ils font des
fautes de français
ils ont à deux débiles absolu qu'est ce
qui se passe mardi 2 2 2b faire des
blagues
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand vous
expliquer donc sincèrement c'est
qu'effectivement il tourne 24 heures sur
24 et que attend attention 24/24 de
tournage d'accord c'est de la télévision
dont il capte les moments les plus
drôles vous comparer ça avec un repas
qui dure 30 minutes au bout de 45
minutes
mais enfin marchand moi vous savez vous
comme moi parce que c'est la télé quand
on fume quinquin 24 heures il se passe
des choses ici des choses ya des moments
drôles des mois - drôle de moment plus
d'un alors la province afin de vous
montre que les chauves ou il doit
démissionner excusez moi vous vous êtes
où je suis quoi des moments dans la
journée
ap ap les limiter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya des moments de la journée vous
êtes satellitaires et je tiens à dire
entre l'eau c'est dur quoi une heure et
demie c'est en général entre le vendredi
c'est un garçon exactement avoue magali
que les candidats tombent et moi on est
un petit peu raccord à boucler leur
accord bah oui alors m'a jamais dit elle
même si peu de sa vie privée rapport
accord mais en tout cas on vous non pas
une guerre de paroisses pour les anciens
et nouveaux moi mais j'aime les gens qui
dormaient vous dis honnêtement autant
changé les temps changent
je vous fais une confidence quand moi je
faisais cycle astori que les anges ont
été lancés on est on passé nous pour des
ringards parce que quand les enfants ont
fait feu faisait des fêtes
aeby saxe perd 1,11 et agglo défilé nul
on a pris un coup de vieux mais par
rapport aux candidats je vous jure que
honnêtement entre ce qui se passait il
ya vingt ans maintenant parce que ça
pose que 20 ans et aujourd'hui
excusez moi les matchs qu on qu'on
reçoit alex est pas là mais pardon
marche alors excusez-moi j'ai juste
donné un truc et vous allez me donner
raison je pense c'est que je donnerais
vous quand vous regardez la télé réalité
où quand toi tu participes à le cimenter
on connaîtra aussi pas très bien et pas
très intéressant et ma vie est en train
de vie parce que la suivante évidemment
le loft il a raison mais là